[Music]
so Jenny thank you so much for being
here with us today
Thanks it's a it's a real honor to have
you here and as you know there's a
slight interest in tech here at Stanford
so a particular honor to have one of
those powerful executives in the
industry but if I may I'd like to pull
you back to the beginning of your career
you started off in the automobile
industry what prompted the move to tech
well III I listen to as John was
describing that he said how many years
right are y'all looking at me thinking
[Laughter]
and I also we were just outside talking
about this you've had Mary Barra here
too right so because I started actually
at General Motors and so so how did I
where did why did I move I have to tell
you something and it's a it's a kind of
an interesting story General Motors had
at the time back when I went to
university and I went to Northwestern
and I was putting myself through school
and back in those days GM offered me a
scholarship no strings attached nobody
does that anymore but no strings
attached help me with school if I would
just work in the summers and I felt a
great obligation then to to try and so
but what I would always say to people
would I learned it what I thought was a
really young age at the time is that I
learned the importance of passion about
what you did and it isn't and I say to
Mary you love cars you know I like
helping you but I wasn't in love in fact
I was working on trucks and buses okay
and I'm like I wasn't in love and and it
taught me something and I probably
didn't crystallize it till later in life
that it was the importance of being
passionate about what you do and I and I
guess that's so easy to say especially
for everybody here who's you're doing
something now you like or you will do
but boy life is too short and so you've
got to keep moving till you find what
that is and I'm not even sure you I knew
what it was at the time I could only see
what it wasn't and so that was what made
me move and so I cuz I said I love
technology because I was an engineer I
loved it
but I wanted to apply it to do things
and and that's what led me then back to
it and it actually wasn't much
I could tell it was a really complex job
search I had looked they had had a lot
of job offers but at the time I was
getting married and my husband was from
the Midwest and so I know for all the
job offers I had on the West Coast they
couldn't understand why was I not
leaving the cold the snow of Chicago
until I finally admitted I was getting
married and I was moving over here and I
ended up there for us I thought a lot of
I said where could I go that I could use
technology in any industry and that's
what let me dive yeah so passion was my
first lesson at a really young age to
learn well passion clearly worked you
are now the CEO of one of the most
iconic companies in the world to those
of us sitting in these seats it can
occasionally be daunting to think about
the journey to being CEO can you tell us
whether you were ever intentional about
taking that job and what kind of the
challenges might have been on the way
well let me let me do a poll so this is
somewhat interactive all right so how
many people think they want to be CEO of
anything okay so half half how many are
not sure the other half yeah okay or the
other third right so to speak because I
was talking to Jordi about this I said
you know what I never that was never a
goal it was never ever a goal for me and
I think there's a lesson in that because
I I think there's been a lot of people
who've always said you gotta have this
has got to be a mission you've got to
want to do this you know people who want
this job stake it out and go for it and
I'm don't prescribe to that school I
prescribe to the school that you you
just keep doing what it is you love to
do you do it great it opens a door you
do something else and that sort of led
to this place right so I can't say I
ever started that way I know people want
me to say that but I can't say that it
that it was really that way but I think
the other thing if I can not that if you
have it as a question or now but the
other thing I would you made me think of
though was again if I can share
something of value on this I do think
people often say to me and John when you
introduced me you said I'd been at IBM
now it's 37 years and that may seem like
a long well it's obviously double most
of your ages or something so
but so why did I stay right people will
say why did you stay and in addition to
being passionate I mean I feel really
strongly whatever you go do do something
with purpose you can define what that
means but do something with purpose and
I always felt to this day in different
ways and I'll come back to maybe even
now as CEO but is that IBM had a purpose
in this world in that this world would
be different if it wasn't for IBM and it
doesn't mean everything we do is that
way and they'll be clearly things other
great companies and you'll go off and do
but but but there are so many things I
can point back in time and forward to
and say wouldn't have existed without
and that's this idea of purpose and so I
started you said as an inter Johnson as
an engineer but I've done engineering
I've done sales I've done research i've
done finance i I feel like I've had a
hundred careers I did a consulting
company I did a technical company you
know all within one place so that
ability to work from anything you can
dream of and then in those wildest
moments it has purpose you know and I
was thinking the other day a colleague a
client I had met about seven years ago
we had started some work together
you mentioned Watson and we started in
healthcare Health Care's one of the most
difficult and you know any who's in
healthcare who wants to be in healthcare
and some way related it is obviously one
of the most important things to change
it's almost difficult things to change
and it varies around the world and what
the systems are but anyways I've always
said for IBM it was going to be one of
our moon shots moon shots meaning I know
how hard it is to change I mean it's so
obvious the problems so if it's so
obvious why can't it get changed and so
there are many many reasons in anyways
we started on this and I only tell you
this story back to purpose was I will
always remember going down the street in
New York one day was with my I was with
my husband in someone she called my name
out and I turned around and it was a
client we were working on the beginnings
of Watson and healthcare and I could
always remember she grabbed my shoulders
he said you know we will change the face
of healthcare my little part
I'm under no illusions that I will
change you know my little part those to
me those are the moments you live for
and so that is why state did you ask me
that question though I felt like telling
you that story I don't know why I felt
it was important face time I don't know
what but go ahead I think what always
tell it that was a thank you more
interesting also than my question was
okay why do you stay here sorry no it's
not interactive we're cutting that off
I looked you've got you've had a lots of
different jobs already about yeah
several experiences right experiences
not only with any purpose or I'm here no
do you believe about purpose though
doing something about purpose or just
more I'm just curious I do now I'm not
trying to put you on the spot I am I am
serious does it seem important now or
maybe later I think it always seems
important I think any purpose is
something that need a lot of people here
think about a lot and it's one of the
reasons why older people come to
business school I mean it isn't the only
reason don't so don't make it I don't
mean it to be as an altruistic point cuz
I think you can you can do multiple you
have commercial value and purpose at the
same time right you can learn and have
purpose at the same time and I think
those are those companies that offer
that wonderful combination and it isn't
as if it's like all you have to do every
moment of every day right so that's all
I just I think you will find many
opportunities to do both so throughout
your career when you were faced with
choices other companies trying to lure
your waiver greater personal commercial
value was always that that purpose you
found at IBM that kept you I think you
know this purpose is that I actually if
I can this purpose point I think is an
important point right now in this moment
in time
geordie and I were talking about before
I got out here I just came back from
well feels like it was a long time ago
thing was last week the World Economic
Forum and this year I co-chaired it and
I co-chaired it with six other women so
highly unusual and if you think about it
that was decision was made a
ago actually to have this be women to
co-chair it but I thought hard about you
know did I want to do it and why and
it's gonna be related to the question
you just ants asked me so he said
purpose actually this is a really
interesting moment in time for
technology actually for business in
total I feel like this is this wonderful
wonderful we have this opportunity to
solve so many problems many you work on
but with them come a set of challenges
that are greater than have ever been in
time before and so the reason I had
agreed to do with was this idea to about
responsible stewardship now maybe
there's a better word but I feel Tek
ourselves as well as even most companies
this idea that what is responsible
stewardship because there is no doubt
these technologies and we will talk a
little bit about it they're going to
impact everybody they're gonna impact
everybody's job and they're gonna happen
faster then other series have happened
before and we have this I think a real
issue of creating a world of haves and
have-nots out there whether it's
businesses whether it's people
individuals and that there is this idea
that you've got to responsibly bring
these technologies into the world so
when you say to me what also keeps me
there it is that belief and I think this
is it really this moment and maybe we'll
talk more about it but this ability to
usher them in with transparency with
purpose that word again to also live by
a set of data principles so the whole
world doesn't end up with all value in a
few hands I think that's wrong and a
third is then a real obligation of
business and government and society to
prepare people to live in this world I
always think it's like you know
transforming a company you can see where
you are and where you want to go you get
killed in the transition and it's always
this transition that makes the
difference and so so why do I say I
believe really strongly that we
understand that stewardship that it is
not enough to make things you have to
bring them safely into the world or your
job is not done
there's a lot you can take your notes
back sorry there's a lot there's lots of
unpacking there and I think that one of
the interesting points is is in a
practical sense how do you balance your
responsibilities to our shareholders
you'll need as a company to drive it's a
real technological leadership with that
stewardship Society how do you do that
on a day to day level what do you think
seriously when you must think of this in
classes right what what what do you
think about for that I honestly have no
idea
I'm not putting out because I think you
actually probably know the answer to
that to be honest with you so to me the
answer is always been and maybe it's
because of our pet you talked about our
past
well first off if you don't define
yourself as a product if you don't
protect your past and then if you try to
do the right thing for the long term I
think you end up in the right place if
you do those three things and so so to
me that balance I always feel like many
of us and again some of you in the
places you go we are allowed to operate
because our clients and society allow us
to operate and that is built on trust
and so you know in the end society or
business will decide if they trust you
and so always with that in my mind I
mean I go back in time things like and
not not accredit any of my decisions by
any stretch this goes back decades when
governments had asked us in many
countries we were talking about you know
today IBM's in 170 countries thirty five
percent of our businesses from the
United States so we've got quite a lot
of experience everywhere else how many
times governments had asked us for
access to technology backdoors into
technology and we're the only Technic
and say we said no from the beginning of
time because our licence to operate was
based on trust and so I think this idea
if that's the role you feel you play and
you make that decision for the long term
and a trust will matter you will
actually make those right decisions and
I think it's true for consumer companies
I don't think it's true for just you
know we're b2b but I think it's true for
everybody
there's a lot of rising mistrust in
technology companies these days I think
and you've seen a lot of tech leaders go
to Washington publicly apologizing how
how do you think the tech industry as a
whole needs to rebrand itself or
re-evaluate its image is all all part of
this communication is it is it being
demonstrative how does that work hmm I
was gonna ask you what you think but I
won't do that okay so so next week
you'll just be me up here seems a little
Y better you are doing good yours well
prepared and so that's in fairness so so
let's just talk a little bit about that
right I let me just pack it in small I
really believe this is a moment in time
for all of us and I say this to all my
clients right this is our moment for
this kind of stewardship you know really
principled stewardship stewardship you
know about how to bring all this
technology and so I think when you do
that you recognize what you are and what
you're not and or what you've become
and so as an example we'll probably talk
a little bit about AI and in na I as an
example is one of the many technologies
but I feel this way about others too
when I say what do you have to do to
build trust well you have to bring it
into the world and be clear about its
purpose its transparency and it's
explained ability so purpose meaning
tell people this is to augment what man
does honestly I wish I wasn't
AI specialist like 30 years ago we
should have been called augmented
intelligence I've been saying this for a
decade because I do really see that will
solve so many great problems but this
will be a world of man and machine and
so they're gonna have to work together
and that is gonna mean a lot of change
and so if you are clear that your
purpose though is to work with not to
replace and I'm not Pollyanna there are
things that will be replaced but then
you'll help people do their job even
better and I see this in I can give you
tons of examples of it so purpose then
transparency you need to I think I need
to tell you when I'm using these
technologies and then I need to tell you
how they were trained I need to tell you
what data got used I need to tell you
where it came from you know it's one
thing if you're asking simple questions
about weather and if we own the weather
company so that
okay no problem you probably you assume
how weather got there the favorite song
but when you're asking about health care
you're asking about a regulation you're
asking about the right treatment for
cancer you care who trained it and so
then the other thing I tell you we've
learned over the mistakes we have made
is you don't have to be able to explain
your answers because if I'm a
professional using a I do I want a black
box how many of you would like to work
with a black box gives you an answer you
don't you want something to say this is
why this is the background this is how
it came up and it took us down different
paths of how to build this kind of
technology because you have to be able
to explain it so to me when you said how
do you build that trust in this moment I
don't think it's about just words I
think it is about real actions you you
clear on your purpose you'd be clear a
transparency you be clear on explain
ability and then you have to live by
things like you own your data I don't
own your data data can freely flow
governments can't have access here's how
I secure it and then you help with
skills so I know that's a lot but I
honestly think that's what we got to do
at this moment in time that is such a
special moment to get this off on the
right foot does that make sense to you
it doesn't make sense I could ask you
everyone but you're right next to me so
it does make some sense to me and I
guess one of the fears they might have
is a someone learning a very traditional
set of skills at business school is how
how am I gonna or meant what I do with
with AI is this something that you think
is really gonna be truly practical in
every industry that we're all denoted
ists are we gonna be replaced by the
machine inside you don't I hope nobody
how many people believe you're replaced
by machines seriously I mean the way I
ask to them it doesn't make you want to
answer my question but two brave souls
are they're counting on that I cannot
see that fire at this point so I we just
finished another study there been many
studies I read three more on my way out
Thursday I'm going to be at a big group
of my colleagues on this topic about the
future of work and they're all over the
board right but I believe a couple
things and then I'll answer your
question about that so first off if you
and you guys study technology better
than most in the world what
different about I think the moment we're
in right now is that it has a chance to
have an exponential impact not linear
most of time when things change its
linear improvement improvement you know
goes like this line through it if you go
back in time Moore's law with processors
doubled every 18 months that would be
more exponential if you would go back
then in time the social media networking
where it later became known as
Metcalfe's law that the value would be
the square of the nodes in a network so
yeah the network effect so everybody
talks endlessly about the amount of data
it's not the amount it's if you could
really get learning to happen
exponentially off that I mean off of
that data you would have another
exponential curve caused by learning
that's what I think's in front of us so
if that's true this third kind of big
exponential curve in life then you'd say
does it replace everything I don't think
it replaces everything it does change
everything so we've done all these
studies it could be five percent of jobs
tempers I don't think it matters I think
it's a hundred percent change so you
prepare for that world and I was my own
so two ends of a spectrum and one of the
very earliest things we did was
healthcare and started in oncology
extremely difficult and and it's been an
interesting road and an interesting
learning so first off time does matter
with some of these technologies to get
started so you may think of Watson for
Jeopardy but much much much as
transpired since that time in fact
november/december the oncologist which
is the most trusted sort of peer
reviewed Journal of oncology put out a
study on Watson a thousand patients
tumor board and we were able to find 30%
more than 30% of the cases new things
that should have been followed than what
a doctor could find that's not an insult
to doctors but there's a learning here
right because how many professionals
ever want to be told they missed
something or they got something wrong
it's very difficult and so there's a
whole change management side to what's
gonna really happen here and but I then
take that same situation and we're now
up to a hundred thousand patients in
oncology treatment in India and China
see because there there's only one
oncologist for 1600 patients here
there's one for a hundred it's a very
different world and so that sort of idea
that motherhood's how does that saying
go necessity is the mother hood of
invention of ever it's gonna leapfrog I
think in driven by perhaps other parts
of the world for different reasons
unless specialization so they're there
the doctors are learning and saying oh
my god I can't do this job by myself I
mean it's impossible for almost any
professional right to do this so I
learned this lesson with that and the
technologies continued to learn faster
and faster I remember the very first
cancers took 9 to 12 months to teach now
30 to 30 days a new cancer 30 days a new
cancer so this idea will your job change
I think everybody's will in
professionals at one end of a spectrum
and I said there's another end of a
spectrum just to give you a feel for why
I say this my own HR I actually think I
you know most people anybody want to be
an HR professional one okay see there we
go now it is most people would is a it's
a difficult job be there's a lot of
administration that people think
continue you know typically associated
with it
I've got a fantastic leader who spent
four years I think making it the most AI
cognitive profession in the world now
it's changed everybody's job but it has
got everything to do with how
recruitment is done proactive retention
compensation so there's no bias in it as
an example everything to do with not
only answering your questions helping
your career what should you learn and
that is applied everywhere along the way
and that to me is like a really normal
good example of how life changes for all
of those jobs and they all changed it
does make a difference in that you have
people with less training and skill able
to do jobs and it puts a premium on
being an expert on the other side
because they things go very quick from
beginning to expert you almost skip
right over those does that make does
that that's kind of world I think will
be in definitely and to go kind of away
from AI but still the future of work
something that really struck me as I was
researching for this interview was IBM's
pathways to technology schools as
already tell us a little more about
and the mission and how you think a
future high school is well we'll go
through the education well how many of
you how many people think that kids
coming out of school have the right
skills to be successful broadly speaking
not your neighbors okay it is it was the
neighbor part that des stopped you or
the you're like oh my neighbor's kids
forget it no this we this can i I want
to this is something I would like to
either get some opinion we're gonna have
some lunch afterwards some input from
folks this started with I believe back
to this point with this moment of
technology changing everything that the
skills issue is a really big issue
around the world and I don't look at it
just in a zip code in an estate in one
place in this country I believe it's
what's giving rise to all of the
political upheaval we've seen there are
people that don't view they have a
better future in front of them there is
a world of haves and have-nots and that
to me is a very dangerous place to go in
for any economy and so I think the route
when you track back on all of this is
skills and so Geordi asked me about this
thing called pathway to technology that
we started so this is a wonderful
University but I don't believe in the
whole globe you can say to people you
only have a future if you have a stem
degree or you have a university degree I
believe strongly in those I mean that
doesn't mean I don't believe in those
but for the billions of people on this
earth that is not going to be the future
and so how do you therefore back to man
and machine and how can people have a
really productive future make a good
income in have skills relevant and so I
think there'll be three things you have
to do one of them is for the youth
coming through we came up with this idea
called pathway to technologies there's a
hundred thousand kids in these schools
now so you may say a hundred thousand is
a drop in the bucket for billions of
people on the earth but it's not it's a
reasonable start a hundred thousand and
it was the idea could you take a high
school everybody and we're now in six
countries take a high school in some
countries would call it different things
but a community college nearby think of
it as a six year high school and could
you come out with skills that would be
employable in in a tech world
and we've proven that it is pretty true
do double the median income and we
picked the worst kids in the worst
schools everywhere in the world that we
could find to start with we did not
cherry-pick anything and it is
heartwarming I mean every parent wants
for their child a better future
I don't care where you are from or what
country you are from and every kid if
given the opportunity so a we help them
with curriculum B we give them mentors
and see if we have jobs we give them a
chance and and I got 300 other companies
like ours did you go in on this
everybody and everybody's happy to
mentor a kid there isn't I've never met
someone who wouldn't do it yet and this
idea I think is becoming a bit viral I'm
gonna do all the governors of this
country I guess it's February this month
already get every state going so there's
about ten states that it's already going
kind of viral in and I think this is
gonna be something that every back to
like social responsibility every company
can do something here
every company it's gonna have to be a
public-private partnership to address
the skills issue in this planet and and
many of my colleagues have different
ways or something like it but it will
take that and then there'll be the
section of retraining which is only is
also one of the hardest again back to
this this dislocation here so whether we
do a lot of retraining and others do and
then I think it leads to something else
which is gonna be society in
government's coming up with ways that
say you know what this idea that you
like go to school until the University
and you're done this is not going to
work out so well we're gonna have to do
something with lifelong learning and
those of you that look at social systems
that do some encouragement that people
continually go back and do that so what
do you think of that idea pretty cool
pretty cool okay it's heartwarming I
mean the only thing I did not count on
is that some of these kids this has
really been an interesting thing for me
the kids they have their kids so it's
okay to call them kids they have you
give them this chance so six years which
by the way you guys would never know
this the typical community college in
this country it takes seven years to
graduate from a two-year school and even
at that like 7% of kids
I mean it's ridiculous and partly it's
cuz the curriculum they don't teach
anything employable and and that's how
they're funded so we've been working
with the government to get them to
change that to say you can't just give
schools funding they got to teach an
employable skill and that's not just a
vocation so but but the funny starting
to tell you is what we had learned so to
get going we've got kids graduating in
four years with an associate degree in
three years also with an associate
degree so when we offered him jobs back
to my HR they came back to like hey you
realize these kids are not like eighteen
yet I'm like oh that's a problem isn't
it so they're like we got a like pay for
their mother to come with them too you
know and so they got a live somewhere so
for their internships but anyways we've
we've managed through all that and it's
to me it's it's it's very heartwarming I
mean in many of them by the way go on to
four-year universities that never ever
ever would have anyways so it's both
ways right because I don't want you to
say I'm down on I'm not it's to me about
giving people a chance right that really
is heartwarming and these initiatives
are fascinating but I would like to
change tack slightly to talk bit more
about IBM it's a company as the Dean
said that's transformed itself several
times you're taking it through another
transition right now I think we'd all be
interested to know a little bit more
about what transformational leadership
means to you and how it's become so
deeply embedded within IBM's DNA yeah so
so IBM a hundred and seven years old
right only tech still here three
generation after generation only one and
and maybe it's because we've had a few
near-death experiences that teaches you
forever to be humble and forever to
realize you have to reinvent yourself
and so as I suddenly started like don't
my learnings of my from my predecessors
don't protect your path don't define
yourself as a product and then do the
right thing for the long term no matter
how strong the short-term wins are in
your face which is what we have done
John you mentioned were 46% new products
and services in the last several years
so in a word what we reinvented IBM
around maybe I can convince some of you
to come come work for us I'll I'll hold
that as my grade of whether I did a good
job today
maybe in a word it was the word data
you're probably not surprised at that
right it was an honest I had sort of
come up with this I thought it was corny
at the time a decade ago a saying that
said data would be the world's next
natural resource because I thought the
analogy was really good that like oil
there are very poor countries with oil
so you can have a lot of data doesn't
mean you get any wealth from it or any
value from it and but those who did in
the technologies were happening could
make a difference you marry that with we
had done all this work on just forget
the background a two trillion dollar
market to make better decisions I'm like
what we all probably think we all don't
make great decisions all of the time so
better make in any profession that would
be out there and so that's what we
started and set out to do and that is
what has been really at the root of this
so it meant having to transition to the
cloud transition to Big Data to
transition to AI but I would be the
first to tell you guys we do it in a
business context and there is a
difference and so just like when I think
about artificial intelligence for
consumers versus for professionals I see
a very strong difference as an example
what we've had to build for is things
like it has to learn domain data so you
have to learn regulatory environments I
talked about medicine you have to learn
HR you have and that means you have to
learn off of very small amounts of data
that's a different kind of AI you don't
have billions of records to look at you
might feel like there's billions of
regulations but they're not I mean so
you have to learn off of very small
amounts that's point one second to
second part we felt like you know what
80% of the data is not searchable in the
world it belongs to our clients I better
protect it for them and I better not
just protect the data I got to build
this in a way that the insights because
that's actually it's more valuable stays
with them and doesn't train something
for the competitor that is a very
different kind of AI that's not an AI
that came from a search engine so
because I've got to protect those
insights for the and I'll come back to
why that is meaningful
it also means in this kind
world you would have to you would have
to be able to explain like I was talking
about earlier you have to be able to
explain where the answers came from in
consumer not so much required but
definitely required when it's a
professional that you're dealing with so
those are some of the differences and so
we've been remaking both our AI all of
our cloud systems all of our expertise
and then you got to put it in workflow
because this again was my biggest
learning I'm telling you the technology
alone in a business environment does not
matter you have got to be able to change
and reimagine the process of work so we
had to build all those capabilities in
there and always underpinned by security
and then this won't be the end
I mean blockchain quantum are all things
we've been heavily heavily invested in
and if I can humbly say I believe in
quantum I know I'm out and I know where
I'm at I do know where I am but I
believe we're number one and and
blockchain even - for for business
reasons blockchain I didn't say Bitcoin
and so I know you had Jamie out here
I've had endless discussions with him on
that so so today that's what IBM is I
mean it is we've always lived uniquely
at this innovative technology industry
expertise trust and security
intersection always reinvented for this
next moment and so I want my again I'm
gonna be with my colleagues in another
day I am very optimistic I know many of
you want to do startups and you will do
and do great things I'm equally
optimistic about current companies that
are out there because as I say to all of
them I feel like this is the moment for
the incumbent disruptor and why do I
feel this this is the moment for the
incumbent disruptor if you believe it's
a future differentiated by data and
knowledge and you own 80% of it if you
can do something with it this is your
moment now to take it in as I've said it
just may be better to have had a past
than not to have had a past and so I see
this in their actions in many companies
right now you see it in Walmart coming
back you see it and it's this is now
their moment they've actually got
something that if they're able to
harness it and do something with it can
differentiate them and they build a
platform on there
expertise and so I think it really those
of you that work on business models it
is a time of soul-searching for lots of
companies on what's their business model
they're saying to themselves you know am
I a car rental company or you know
actually what I know how to do is fleet
management I'm moving cars around all
the time and in the world of autonomous
cars fleet management might be a pretty
good thing to know how to do so I mean I
think everybody's going through that
about what it is they can do with all
that data and what they their knowledge
is and so that's what IBM has become
it's the platform for that and you you
brought it up so I'll I'll ask there are
lots of students here considering offers
from Google and Facebook and the likes
why should they go to the IBM instead I
convinced you yet okay let me ask you
more questions okay
no chests so look I think it goes back
to where you and I started and they will
do some Q&A here I would come to IBM for
three reasons a you got to be passionate
about the impact technology can have in
the world B you got to want to change
the way the world works I mean we do
work on serious stuff that changes the
way the world works it doesn't mean we
work on everything so other people will
do other pieces but there isn't a bank
that we don't run and help reinvent
there is not a credit card transaction
there's not a railroad car that runs and
these are serious obligations about how
that happens safely and how it then at
the same time reinvents itself so this
idea that to help change some of what
not everything but to change part of how
the world works is more let's just say
it is certainly what we aspire to every
day okay I mean only the world can
determine whether you do or don't and so
I'd come for that purpose I'd come for
that strong strong passion about the
technology in the third it's something
you know what it's something I actually
took for granted to the last couple
years it is a strong environment of
inclusion I have never never in my world
I was interviewed not very long ago
after many of the incidents of this past
here about inclusion and I said you're
not gonna be honest with you
I've never felt that way and III in you
might find that so hard to believe
are there isolated incidences I have
380,000 employees of course of my scale
in the in the world but I said I have
never I have never felt anything any
limit on myself I put there it was never
put on me by IBM and I said that I think
that is such a deep root it goes back to
having hired the first disabled person
in 1914 the first woman executive is
1943 I mean this is I look now and I
think others you've got to be kidding me
I've taken all this for granted and I no
longer take it for granted right and I'm
proud of the the culture I didn't build
it I have only had to carry it on right
and be sure it got even more and I use
the word inclusion not diversity on
purpose to me inclusion is about sexual
orientation gender religion country
ethnicity I don't care what it is right
that you feel comfortable this is why we
have fought you know and I can't fight
every battle we have fought so hard for
the dreamers we have fought so hard
around these bathroom bills these crazy
things but they were so symbolic about
people feeling welcome in their
workplace in those states I happen to be
a big employer in Texas and North
Carolina too so that was but and we got
those stopped and but is it because of
just that one thing it could you can't
fight everything you know it was because
that was very symbolic to me about
inclusion and so I feel that environment
then and it's what we do even now you
know whether it's women I am very proud
guys we will have won this thing called
the catalyst or door the only tech
company and the only company on earth to
have won at four times about inclusion
and women in the workforce so that would
be my third reason it would be passion
purpose and inclusion yeah
well I finally said something that made
sense perhaps he's almost right that
perhaps a fourth reason could be we've
got a lot of crypto investors out here
we can be talking about more about
blockchain and your what iBM is doing
there and maybe right from the inclusion
to blockchain yeah excellent segue here
how many okay who's it who's a
blockchain lover okay baby I think a
small group on some meet later not a big
group about how about bitcoin lover Oh
subset okay so can I just say the reason
I those of you didn't raise your hand if
I could encourage you to go look into
black chain is a you think why am i
bringing this up as a technology I
honestly think the future on blockchain
I have a little saying blockchain will
do for trusted transactions what the
internet did for information and I
believe this very very strongly its
ability to trade transactions between
people who don't necessarily know each
other not necessarily trust each other
in a way to remove friction and the
movement of about anything I think is
quite high and what makes it so possible
to really get some traction is it you
don't have to rip out the guts and
rewrite everything if you're a company
to be able to use it so the movement to
it is not that difficult and so you had
Doug McMillon here from Walmart so Doug
and I started a project on food safety
you would be shocked at the number of
people who died from food and how much
food is wasted at food outbreaks so how
on earth could we get every competitor
of his and every food company in the
world to join onto this their
competitors and they're gonna share all
the information about what kind of food
avocados spinach um right but the
spinach breakout what happened all that
spinach wasted and in it typically we
did we've done the tests on many things
now but mangoes seven days to trace
where our mango come came from we do it
in two seconds now so this idea of
solving that problem we're doing a big
joint venture with the largest shipping
company in the world Maersk we've
already the paperwork that accompanies a
big cargo
container exceeds the value of the
contents of the cargo came often so
there is so much opportunity now I said
all that it is not about Bitcoin there's
something under it called blockchain and
it does matter how you implement it and
you have to have it be permissioned some
of what's out there is opaque I don't
believe those will be what will take off
you can't have people that will in fact
some of I won't use their names other
companies that have stuff out there it
is a little bit an artist and you know
it will allow crime to go on quite
freely that is not what we're talking
about we're talking about where
permission means I know who's on the
network I can tell the Loom that
Professor here can only see three things
you can see five I know who governs this
thing I mean who do you think governs
the internet right there is a governing
body it's not two people so there's a
big open we're a big fans of open source
there's a big it's the fastest growing
open source hyper ledger is the name of
it community there's been in time out in
the Linux Foundation and so it's
governed by 200 companies now that's a
good thing you have to have it be
immutable anyways I won't give you a
lecture on blockchain but I'm so I'm so
optimistic about the things that it can
do on the positive like food safety in
the inefficiencies it can take out to go
to better things on the other side it's
the fundamental technology not a comment
about crypto currencies that's kind of
different but but I guarantee you
whatever you do without having
government's have an ability to see some
of the money transfers you're not gonna
be able to take off so you're gonna go
into that now no I'll stay I'll stay
clear that okay and want one last
question before we turn to turn to
audience Q&A I've been struck by the
number of times you mentioned that the
healthcare industry and cancer in
particular and I know you're you're on
the board of Moral sloan-kettering is
there a reason why this is such a way
this is a mission that's very personal
to you or is it just that you see this
is the area of the biggest improvement
to me it is the biggest use of our GDP
and it's the biggest inefficiency with
the lowest return and it's true in a
developed country like ours guys but you
I mean I've spent so much time in Africa
India China
these are unsolvable problems in these
places these people have never ever have
a chance to get health care of the
quality you and I experience it if any
of us have cancer we will be seen by a
Cancer Center odds of that happening
outside this country are like zero I
mean in the other outside of developed
country and so that does not have to be
that way and this is this is to me I
mean I guess I did call it a moonshot
right and lot to be learned from that
but I think all of us in our companies
get a chance to work on some of those
right so it was health care but go back
on the other side I'm a biggest fan of
trying to help reg reg tech and I really
basic things as well right improve on
the other side but to me us in what
we've done is started in healthcare is
very sim it was very symbolic and
important and I think it's a really hard
journey but it is a deadly disease with
many variants and it's impossible we
started with cancer so we started in the
hardest spot is it's an impossible to do
without the assistance of these kind of
technologies thank you so much any
before you have time to ask me any more
questions then turn over to the audience
maybe you'd like to ask him a question
Michael
[Applause]
okay anyone hi there
my name's Catherine I'm an MBA - my
question is related to your time
chairing the World Economic Forum I
think the World Economic Forum is one of
the coolest ways that private and public
leaders can work together to solve
problems in a top-down way but as the
world becomes increasingly decentralized
how should the World Economic Forum
change and adapt to better address these
problems that's oh it is it is a good
tops down but I think what happens when
you leave the World Economic Forum it
becomes a Bottoms Up effort of what
people can do and I will tell you this
year a majority of it a lot of it was on
skills issues and how do how everybody
can work in partnership with that so I
think what it can do don't try to put
more into it than it's capable of right
so it isn't as if it's a standing body
it is a standing body but an
organization that can actually have
rules or committees standards and it's
more about I think putting standards out
there that can be followed in the rest
of the world this is a really critical
time you know as different countries
move more inward with each other it's a
dangerous moment you know right now
Europe is setting many many standards
around data
honestly America should be in there
because they're gonna end up sending
setting the de facto standards here so
you probably regulations like GDP are
global data protection it's gonna end up
being a global standard right and and
we're not at the table as much as we
should be I know every time I'm in
Europe and in Brussels the it's a you
know they're dying for companies to come
fill a void that may be a scene is avoid
by governments right now and so I think
what can happen on when you said what
happens next
I do think companies can help in this in
this time particularly where you might
want to call it more and more countries
look out for themselves are more
nationalistic whatever words you would
like to put around it I think it it
calls for those of us going back
particularly around things like you know
modernization of trade skills in the
world and we didn't talk much about
cybersecurity right and
in in cyber in that impact because cyber
is the one thing that will will stop all
the it'll take three steps forward and
five steps back right with cyber here
with what happens so I think that's what
we can all go back and do I am I always
remember a meeting years ago that I'd
had with Shimon Perez late in his life
and I remember a quote he he had said to
me I don't know why it's always stuck
with me but maybe it's cuz I I feel it's
true he said companies can do more to
help countries and governments because
they know no boundary and it's true if
you those of you that were you know you
don't I don't really don't really see
boundaries that way and so I think it's
an important that's the important
follow-on is what this public-private
partnership becomes thank you very much
for your time my name is Yahya I'm from
Saudi Arabia I'm a joint degree
candidate here doing MBA M master's in
electrical engineering so my question to
you was how can a I help businesses that
are outside the US or Europe where the
infrastructure that allows AI to let
these businesses flourish like
intelligent investors or talent like
data scientists or something are not
available in these countries or
locations yeah I look I think first off
many of what we offer is a platform that
is available in any country it may not
run in the country but it's running
somewhere else as a platform and I was
telling John ahead of time about one of
your one of your colleagues here
Joshua Browder who is one of your
colleagues I mean I met him only because
why would I ever meet him other than he
found Watson and he then built a
business called do not pay for people
who shouldn't pay parking tickets that
they got wrongly and I think he's
handled by 200,000 parking tickets those
of you that know the story 11 million
dollars but he's working on Syrian
refugees now and how to get them the
right paperwork to stay in different
countries and so I think this is more
accessible you know when we do work in
Saudi Arabia as well this is more
accessible than you think and so to me I
think this is a wonderful technology to
allow entrepreneurs as well as big as
them coming together actually see a lot
for the coming together between those
two constituents and if you think of it
as a platform it's more accessible than
not accessible albeit some issues in
certain countries but still accessible
the back I'm Ching hall from the MSX
program IBM is a company of global giant
with a storied history I'm wondering how
you keep the IBM family nimble creative
and innovative is it more of a top-down
or bottom-up approach or just here view
what's your perception I think it has to
be so yeah I think it has to be both
myself I'm from the Air Force is a big
organization anytime you want to get
something going you want to start small
you want to create space for people by
the same time you need some top-down
direction to say this division I'm just
wondering if you have a slightly
different take on it I I do
I mean not that this has been one of my
biggest learnings perhaps one of my
biggest mistakes as well so big you know
Geordi asked me this so IBM is today an
80 billion dollar company in 170
countries we talked about 46 percent of
it new lots of new entrants obviously
into this technology field and so how do
you get changed to happen fast so I tell
you my quick like I'll try to make a
very quick story but what my learning
was so probably my first two years of
CEO I would say to the group because
it's true the world is moving so fast
come on faster faster faster you got to
work it I mean I think if anyone would
have said what does she talk about they
would decisions and to go faster go
faster and go faster go faster go faster
at costly and I thought about after
tiers what did I do
I exhausted them that's about what I got
done until it dawned on me that I have
to check it's my job and we got to
change how work is done and I'll tell
you so while much will ever be written
about the portfolio and how it's changed
I think them far more what one day you
know revisionist history one day when
we're distanced enough we will look back
in the far more interesting story will
be how work gets done in what happened
to the people and to their skills and
I'm the how what we had to learn was we
were a b2b company so the shortcut of
this is it meant you can be big and be
fast but you do have to re-architect
work and that means a lot of things like
even in b2b hey they expect everything
to be as simple as the consumer world we
all live in everyday
that means design thinking that means we
hired ten thousand of the best designers
from around the world brought back that
culture that had once existed by the way
in IBM everything is done with empathy
from the end end-user in and not from an
engineering culture out which is what a
lot of tech companies are engineering
out and so it started with that then it
started with really agile easy buzzword
really hard to change the way you do
work unless you truly embrace it so we
probably now 200,000 agile experts
trained black belts it means small
multidisciplinary co-located Minimum
Viable products and think about Minimum
Viable products I mean when you think of
big things we do like run Airlines banks
you think of these big complex things
going fast doesn't mean like make that
big ugly thing faster it means no but it
means start with something little get it
right make it bigger make it bigger make
it bigger that's way different on the
way you build things so we had to change
what agile put that in what did it mean
then we had a co-locate you know talk to
me about a billion dollars later in real
estate you know renovations and all that
kind of thing around the world and so
it's been you know we had to change the
performance management system we had to
move to Net Promoter Score I mean sorry
there's like heavy work underneath real
transformations and that's what had to
do to happen to make you work fast so is
that top and that's bottom on top it's
both but I tell you until until we as
leaders help people change how they
could do their work that wasn't going to
happen and so that to me and then the
people on skills the skills part for
anybody train you know changing a
company like actually I'm gonna talk
about this again tomorrow a thing I have
to do we are all gonna have to change
the skills of everybody in our company I
mean I lectured for the first Friday of
every month for four years I taught a
class for four years a MOOC and it was
about what the future was what it would
be had clients on over and over and so
you paint the
sure of the world that you are building
then you have to say to people okay now
I need to make it so you can change your
skills and then I'm going to pay you for
changing them meaning I'm gonna put
compensation for those that then go
ahead and change skills and then the
third thing you have to do after you've
done that kind of reinforcement of it
then you've got to say okay now I'm
gonna make this transparent it's gonna
be obvious we're gonna post who's got
that skill who doesn't have that skill
and that's the world of transparency we
live in stale hot and you'd be surprised
people will move there's nothing to do
with age this is nothing to do with age
and that's why it's changed the way I
even think about hiring we were talking
about what do you you know what school
is it better to hire an MBA or and
there's room for everybody I think the
most distinguishing characteristic is
your curiosity if you are a lifelong
learner I would like you you you that
because that's what's in front of us and
it doesn't matter to me what school you
came out of because that's got to do
with passion you know it's this lifelong
learning so those the thing about the
skills and the people and then changing
how work gets done to me that was that
will one day be the real sets of
learning that comes out of how do
companies reinvent themselves in this
day and age this must be the last
question is it a good one a lot of
pressure or will be the second time I'll
try so thanks so much for coming in my
name's Stephanie young I'm an MBA 3 we
exist is that a good thing it's on the
MBA 3 okay I'm doing a joint program and
my question for you was you talked about
companies potentially crossing borders
that governments couldn't cross I was
curious for you personally with IBM how
you see IBM's role in government in the
US and globally and conversely flip that
and think about what you think
government needs to be doing to make it
effective to make them effective working
with companies like IBM yeah look this
this is a good question cuz I you can
imagine even earlier in the year I got
asked this question many many times
and in with my whole workforce actually
to explain and re explain to them what
is our role and I feel every every IBM
CEO has worked with every United States
president as an example since Woodrow
Wilson and as I said to my workforce and
my teams I say guys this is it not about
politics it is about policies in fact
we're the only we are the only tech I
know of that makes no contributions zero
always had a position about it zero zero
zero everywhere zero by the way when
your answer is like no it's easy to be
consistent no and so don't start and so
but it does give you a freedom to then
you then debate policies and so it's
policy it's not politics and so that is
what I have firmly stuck on is to what
my issues I don't care in every country
we have to deal with because mind you
you know whether it was you know I was
with Prima Modi last week this week I'll
do Prime Minister Trudeau in Canada or
whether it is you know shi Shan ping it
doesn't matter in each country and I've
never met a country that didn't want you
to increase your workforce they're never
labor is the currency jobs is currency I
don't care who you are
that is true for as long as I can
remember so I think what we can do is
each of us so you adapt the things that
are important to you right so what's
important to us is education in every
country that we work on what's important
to us is inclusion and diversity and
this ability and why you want it for
innovation I mean it's not just for an
altruistic reason you want it for
innovation so we're very strong
supporters of open innovation very
strong supporters of Education and very
strong supporter of free trade I mean I
worked really hard on things like TPP
because I think they're not only good
for business they were good for those
countries too it held them to a level in
a standard not to steal IP to let data
flow freely to have wages be a certain
way I mean there were lots of good
things and they were modernized for the
digital era by the way which most print
agreements are not modernized for
so those are some of the main issues we
have really devoted ourselves to and of
course in the u.s. we've wanted a
competitive tax system right and so
because otherwise it allows other
countries to buy companies here in all
for those kinds of reasons not for the
right reasons so that's to me what we
should do and in return what do you want
government to do well you want them not
to heavily regulate you I've never met a
place that regulation was a really great
thing but there is you do want them to
create in every country a level playing
field so that's what I want out of most
governments and of course the treatment
of people and the focus on education but
that level playing field and that's what
we work on in almost every country which
is about how to be sure there's a level
playing field that people can move
freely ideas can move freely right I
love that old saying you know I just is
true like good ideas have no Passport
right and so that is what you want to be
able to have happen and I and I'm sure
it's why we fought so hard around
immigration too right so that regardless
of country that there should be good and
done a lot of work on the immigration as
well so that would be my take away be
it's always about policies not politics
and if you focus on that my view is you
can change the world you can change the
world
well journey as an international student
struggling to get a job I hugely
appreciate that and also want to say
believe me you answer my questions a lot
better than I could have done so thank
you very very much for coming ladies
engineering
[Applause]
[Music]